- Mi-mince-mince-mince-mince-mince
meat pie.
(upbeat orchestra music)
- Mincemeat pies just reminds me
of like a sad orphan.
- I haven't decided if
meat should be in pies,
except chicken pot pie.
- I know that mince just means like
finely ground, right?
- It's like Sweeney Todd, right?
Except in Sweeney Todd,
he puts humans in there.
- Dude I haven't seen the movie.
You just (beep) spoiled it.
(biting crunch)
- Oh it's cute!
- It's like Honey I Shrunk the Kid.
- This is a mincemeat pie?
- Is this salt?
- Is it sugar?
You've licked it and we're
gonna have to share it.
(laughing)
- Sorry.
- So it is like dessert meat?
- Where's the meat?
(laughing)
- You don't like it?
- I know it's raisins!
- Is it raisins?
It's not even meat?
- Wait, is there meat in
this with the raisins?
- Tastes like a pumpkin spice latte.
- It's better than it smells.
- This is like a gourmet pop tart.
- It's like a Fig Newton.
- So there's no meat in this?
- I hope there wasn't.
- Is this just to say that I'm an idiot?
- Are you trying to kill Santa?
- He can have it.
- Should not be called mincemeat.
Should change to like raisin shortbread.
- Here, have some ice cream cake,
and it's actually filled with salmon.
Like, why did you tell me
it's an ice cream cake?
- I mean the British have given us
so many wonderful things like Dr. Who
but then I question it when I eat this.
- The mincemeat pies were
surprisingly delicious.
- Oh my god I sound like
such an idiot right now.
- I do too.
- God, I just started dating this guy--
- And he's gonna know that you don't know
what a mincemeat pie is.
- Oh (beep)!